[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
blog es ist drei uhr 19 nachts oder
morgens ich weiß es nicht
vielfalt ist es 319 und ihr seht hinter
mir das pure chaos und ich überlegte das
jetzt noch schnell zu machen bevor ich
schlafen gehe ich hab' ich mag noch so
ein blitz marathon die küche ganz schön
auf vordermann bringen so einigermaßen
zumindest aber erst mal kurz zum
heutigen tag ich hatte heute meine
freundin zu besuch
zum start also zum fastenbrechen und es
gab indisch und indisches amazon lecker
und es gab mutter schicken da habe ich
aber auch noch rot paprika gemacht mit
reise mit dem elektrofahrrad und als
nachtisch gab es ja das sind noch so die
überreste das hier mache ich mir gleich
zu einem smoothie und trinkt den und das
tue ich mir in ein schälchen bei
wegschmeißen muss man das wirklich nicht
und hört ihr den herbst im hintergrund
der schneidet gerade fleißig noch videos
also wir sind einfach richtige
arbeitstier im moment wir können es
nicht lassen aber ich wollte unbedingt
meinen blog heute schon beginnen und
dann habe ich die küche auf geschlafen
und bringen euch morgen nochmal durch
den ganzen tag mit nehme euch durch den
tag mit
[Musik]
der nächste tag heute beginnt der tag so
dass hamster produktfotos schießt von
unseren winkel paletten wir haben ja
echt lange gebraucht bis wir eine eigene
winkel palette haben einfach darum weil
das sollen die hochqualitative winkel
paletten sein
die sollen nicht nach ein paar wochen
weggeschmissen von euch sondern wir
sollen ein leben lang halten im besten
fall
und die haben wir jetzt bekommen und wir
haben sie mag hat die fotos ich zeig
euch das macht also so sieht das aus man
sieht mich dass das eine platte ist
später foto sondern einfach nur weiß und
mit dem grauen hintergrund
und jetzt mache ich mich hier schon mal
den pc und macht schon mal die
produktbeschreibungen damit es auch so
schnell wie möglich online geht
[Musik]
mich wundert mich umgezogen et cetera pp
und war kurz einkaufen wird machen ein
produktfoto haben sollen christoffers
das ist übrigens keinen dargestellt das
ist ein echtes tiramisu nike was wird
dass ihr ohne mich dass mit lecker
erdbeer tiramisu und das gleich mit
eingeladen ich weiß dass ich davon haben
wir gerade über historische gesprochen
das ist toll gemacht und dann ja aber
ich fast am ende kommt es beim montreux
auf jeden fall das muss natürlich
einfach das kann ich doch eigentlich ist
so da kann ich machen was mich so an
aber ich kann euch machen fehler
wir müssen richtig packen weil das ist
noch hier einfach hier mit biskuits okay
dann zum nächsten abschnitt
ich hab ich mal so ich bleib doch hier
oder lang doch hier ja etwas gepflegter
es hat spaß gemacht heute gibt es bei
dir wo bist du eigentlich werden das ist
die frage haben sie geht und auswärts
essen
ich habe angeboten dass ich was machen
oder ich komme ja vor der zimmer und
einen teller oder sitze ich da gesehen
wie schön ist auch keine gabel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so meine lieben jetzt verlasse ich die
wohnungen gibt es meiner freundin nennt
ehrt mich und andere freunde zum
fastenbrechen eingeladen und dann sehen
wir uns trügen wieder
[Applaus]
daumen hoch lassen er kommt nach hause
wann wirst du still
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
nach hause darauf mich erlaubt sein in
der bude
das ist so sicher nicht zu setzen
wo ist ein paket das ist unser
couchtisch und das sind bilder haben ja
ich hab ganz die bilderrahmen was es
geht ja wohl gar nicht dass die wände so
weiß jetzt durch das mal weiße wände
weiße wände weiße wände ein verwaistes
bild von meiner schwester weiße wände
weiße wände hause ein hanser die
richtung heute warte man warte mal
wieder ärger ich hab's euch voll
verschwiegen ich war nämlich heute nach
der computer also zwischen
computerarbeit und den fotos
produktfotos waren wir bei einem
großhändler aus der umgebung und haben
dafür den shop eingekauft überschrift
uns nicht überall mitnehmen
ja ich will unbedingt ich bestelle mir
jetzt ein für die haare zum locken 30
zwischenstopp am morgen statt
ich besitze mit meinen 620 erkenntnissen
starb und heute hole ich mir endlich ein
weil sie das geld
machen sie mit und danke ich mal locken
ein neuer tag meine lieben heute ist es
sonntag
und heute sind wird zum fastenbrechen
bei hansens eltern und ich habe mich
schon etwas vorbereitet
aber heute bin ich für das essen
zuständig wir wechseln uns da ab und zu
auch mit schweren und heute habe ich
gedacht weil ich das bis jetzt noch gar
nicht geschafft habe mache ich heute das
gift hier habe ich schon mal türkische
linsensuppe vorbereitet ich film das was
ich mitnehme und das ist ein ofen
gericht mit hähnchenschenkel und gemüse
und ich habe das nicht film das hier
weil wir gehen ja später drüben essen
und dann schiebe ich da in den ofen und
dann können wir da die entstehen auch
nicht alles erhalten was haben wir denn
hier leckere city ich freue mich drauf
aber ich bei der mauer
das ist das nicht ganz verstanden
[Applaus]
ein neuer tag gestern abend haben wir
die staaten gästen behandelt eltern dann
haben wir da noch ein bisschen gesessen
und dann ging es nach hause
nun hat schon bisher schon gemacht und
so weiter ich weiß gar nicht ob ich dann
auch immer so mitnehmen sonst was ich
bitte aber um ehrlich zu sein wirklich
angriffe auf rom zu kommen ich finde es
übertrieben entspannt kann so kann das
nicht verstehen ich mag das ist vor
allem im zeitraffer wenn leute aufhalten
aber da muss jetzt schon richtig schnell
gehen vielleicht noch das heute mit euch
und jetzt sind wir gerade auf dem weg
zum shop da gehen wir jetzt ein paar
pakete verpacken für euch ja noch machen
was er alleine aber wir haben schon
unterstützung von dem neben khan und mal
gucken wir uns das ganze hinführt weil
im moment überlegen sie schon unseren zu
erweitern dass wir dann doch ein
bisschen mehr platz haben wir doch mehr
fahrer aufgenommen haben findet man hier
und da noch so schöne produkte wo man
hinkommt
wir haben schon über 100 produkte haben
schon über 100 produkte im shop
[Musik]
übrigens habe ich schon erzählt dass die
deponie unser zweites zuhause geworden
ist
fertig immer einiges an paketen verpackt
jetzt bin ich wieder zu hause und wir
haben 20 uhr 43 das heißt ich habe noch
gute 40 minuten eine stadt essen zu
machen zu haben wird mich und das
schütteln und jetzt ganz schnell aus dem
ärmel
und der kommt bestimmt etwas leckeres
daraus
[Musik]
hallo aus wasser was gibt's besseres und
dann doch wieder das wasser hammer
[Musik]
richtig handhaben mega aus das sieht
auch dass fabiano film gemacht hast
dabei
dann lass dich da machen wir gerade
produktfotos diese tasten die wollten
unbedingt im shop aufnehmen weil man
kann darin so schöne desserts serbien
die türkei will twitter burgen hatten
was auch immer so genau so schöne sätze
dann im online shop auf jeden fall
wurden da auch mit magnolia und so
serviert richtig schön vermisste die
flitterwochen
wenn du suchtfragen es ja oder nein
hier haben wir denn die auswahl werden
wir keine auswahl nach malaysia wollte
ich schon immer mal aber schon immer so
traum vielleicht schon sind trauen
okay nur 17 wir sind immer noch dabei
waren immer noch produktfotos und jetzt
könnte trainer raten was jetzt kommt
und was passt besser zu als schwarz
gemacht
ein teelöffel für die gesundheit
das muss ich jetzt
[Musik]
das ist schon die allergie ist komplett
ja und das ist in meinem shop oder in
unsere shops errichten was wir dass wir
sind alle produktfotos geschossen alles
in den kasten das letzte produkt foto
zwar spiegelei und das ist sicher schon
ein bisschen kalt geworden aber das
macht mir gar nichts aus dass es sich
jetzt noch mit toastbrot werden schon
ganz spät 3 uhr in langgöns und wie
sehen uns morgen wieder gute nacht
morgen oder besser gesagt mittag ich
werde jetzt ganz kurz meiner
einkaufsliste schreiben denn ich muss
einkaufen ich habe vor für euch
eigentlich sehr abzufilmen kwf und dann
wollte ich gerne noch öfter april
besteht schon lange auf meiner liste und
das möchte ich morgen machen und genau
so ein bisschen die vorräte auffüllen
[Musik]
weil ich mich ganz gut umgezogen und
jetzt müsste es eigentlich losgehen zum
einkaufen aber haben hat mich daran
erinnert wir müssen noch ganz kurz bei
der druckerei anhalten nämlich haben wir
was ein deutsch nämlich haben wir bei
der druckerei für unsere produkte für
die linke paletten und so weiter und für
die koch helfer das sind ja unsere
eigenen produkte und deshalb brauchen
wir dafür noch die verpackung und wir
wollten keine riesen umverpackung haben
sondern einfach nur eins was man
dahinter klemmen kann so wenig
verpackungsmüll wie möglich und es
sollte aber auch trotzdem schick
aussehen und da gehen wir jetzt mit und
schauen uns im test druck an wer bist du
denn mal so weit auf die man warten muss
die 14 tage lang neben tagen das haben
wir an so ansehen die akie hamza bloggt
nicht locker ja ich bin dicker geworden
ich kann mich doch gar nicht halten
obwohl diese fokussieren kann
aber ich kann mich selber nicht
in den tiefen der tanke auf neue leute
das habe ich interessant aber nein halt
stopp gott inter kurve 1 51
danach stehen halt dann glaube ich
lieber bleib ich lieber einzeln fest
aber wir wollen jetzt eine geschichte
geben ich verstehe das nicht manchmal
klartext es gibt leute die fahren extra
zehn kilometer weiter sein betreiber ist
das 60 meter weiter nur damit sie sich
zwei cent pro liter sparen so erstens
der weg dahin bis heute zwischen
verbrannt und 2008 sogar sehr zäh und
seit babybauch posiert übervoll
ja sagt man nicht doch
der betrag
die abgabe wird
und da geht der zentralrat euro betragen
hitler
jetzt war bei der druckerei für unsere
schätze also das sind ja nur zwei davon
der wird jetzt nur beweise von mir zu
hause mitgenommen und schaut mal so wird
unsere verpackung aussieht
ein heidenspaß das ist sehr wichtig das
mal so das papier ich mag dieses muster
und wie findet ihr das design das ist
jetzt nicht vom von der druckerei
sondern dass es von uns und ich finde
das passt richtig zu und es ist einfach
so schlicht so ein bisschen marrakeschs
teil aber trotzdem noch schlicht nicht
übertreiben wir wollen eigentlich
einkaufen aber das wetter ist so blöd
und im auto ist es so gemütlich bisschen
sitzung seiner heimischen auto aber
haben da kommen wir müssen jetzt
aufpassen ehrlich es gibt sowieso
ich habe wenig später ein kind habe dann
ziemlich mit dem auch nur macht uns
stark mich auch aus den tod
jetzt habe ich meine einkaufstüten daher
muss sie jetzt einmal kurz auf packen
alles einsortieren und eigentlich
wollten haben sie und ich heute ein dsl
tarif machen also mit diesen dünnen
fäden
aber ja wir haben es jetzt 19 06 und
haben sie hat jetzt noch was zu tun für
den shop also am pc sein arbeitszimmer
und ich erledige jetzt gerade in der
küche den rest und bereite schon mal das
essen vor sieht ein bisschen eng mit der
zeit ich glaube dann verschieben wir den
dreh auf morgen gemacht
zwei videos von morgen wollte ich
unbedingt die kräfte ab wenn ich liebe
die köpfe ich habe erstens richtig
hunger drauf und zweitens habe ich euch
das auch schon lange versprochen
dann machen wir morgen ist er und
schickte gucken haben 30 ist du bist
amrum spielen will ist doch fleißig
arbeitest du auch viel um noch so auch
unter junge für mich ist meine haare
gleich welches mein fasten gebrochen nur
stück okay wir sprachen sie zwei sich
zum ersten mal in diesem ramadan nicht
was ich kochen soll sonst hätte ich
immer irgendeinen plan und irgendeine
ahnung hatte tag 15 weise ist einfach
nicht kann mich nicht entscheiden können
wenn ich heiße es nicht leute also fakt
ist ich habe ganz frisches oder mann
samt usd gekauft gerade vom vierteln
also vom ofen von dem türkischen bäcker
eigentlich war der plan raps zu machen
aber doppelt brot ist ja quatsch ich
jetzt aber ich brauche immer in diesen
zeitdruck
19 44 ist ich brauche noch so ein
bisschen mehr zeitdruck das heißt ich
lege sich für so hoch schön auch ein
bisschen und wenn so richtig druck kommt
wenn auch wenn sie richtig druck kommen
so 40 minuten feuchter hat dann überlege
ich das ist doch noch aus dem topf
gelandet und zwar mache ich das an ihr
suppe die lasagne blätter die kommen
gleich erst rein damit die nicht so so
so weit werden ich mache jetzt gerade
dafür freut euch eben zeigen dahin
befüllt mit marzipan
dafür nimmt ihr euch also schneidet sie
hier einmal auf die dafür da sind meine
an berlin hin
da gebe ich jetzt einfach nur marzipan
rein und dann ganz einfach verschließen
sondern schlimmer was rauskommt wenn wir
überziehen das ganze jetzt noch mit
schokolade die ich gerade in der
mikrowelle geschmolzen habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit haben wir gegessen und in dem
arbeitszimmer und jetzt arbeiten wir zu
zweit an einem bildschirm ich zeige euch
mal wie das funktioniert also ich sie
auf den billigen plätzen
ich guck mir links das video an ob das
so in ordnung ist was haben wir
geschrieben haben sie arbeitet rechts an
online shop und wir brauchen unbedingt
gardinen diesen schon bestellten und nur
noch nicht ausgepackt haben sagt so und
jetzt verabschiede ich mich so langsam
dass der blog auch nicht zu lang wird
ich hoffe natürlich dass es euch
gefallen hat da haben sie natürlich auch
noch chips so richtig ist die familie
wie beim letzten block gelungen heißt
auch am pc bearbeiten und wirklich
gemerkt los ist wieder da aber wir
wünschen euch jetzt noch einen schönen
tag oder abend oder also auf eine zeit
bräuchte man ist ja nie was zu tun ist
kommentieren und neigten abonnieren und
das bisher schon vorbei aber falsch
gedacht habe sagt gerade fertig
geschnitten und dafür noch ein ich
erzähle euch was euch im nächsten block
erwartet ich koche einfach da für zwölf
personen wenn ihr das nächste mal dabei
sein wollt dann auf jeden fall
einschalten und zu sehen ob ich es nicht